[Music]
Elsa
the past is not what it seems you must
find the truth go to the enchanted lands
and into the unknown promise me we do
this together okay I promise every day's
a little harder as you feel my power
grows don't you know there's a part of
me that loves you
into the and
into the
it's the
[Applause]
I believe in you us
or anything
[Music]
far away as north as we can go once
stood an enchanted forest you see an
enchanted forest yes it was a magical
place but something went wrong since
then no one can get in or that was
paddock what would I do without you
you'll always have me
[Music]
how's Elsa seemed weird to you she seems
like Elsa
there's just voice voice what does that
mean
the kingdom is not safe find who is
calling to you they may have answers I'm
going with you
Anna no excuse me I climb to the North
Mountain survived two frozen heart and
saved you from my ex-boyfriend so you
know I'm coming
normally
where are we
Howdy's get in the forest then this
party for her has impossible where did
you learn magic
[Music]
you can't just follow me into fire and
don't run into fire
[Music]
magic is very alluring without you she
may lose herself
protect arendelle at all cost
I believe in you Elsa more than
[Music]
quick question is the whole putting up
the mortal danger gonna be a regular
thing
[Music]